The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's go
ahead and get started.
We're actually not
going to be joined
by our friends in
Zaragoza today,
but we're still
going to be recorded.
So still have to stay on
our best behavior, I guess.
Today we're going to go
through life cycle assessment,
and talk about
that and how we use
it to quantify environmental
impacts of products.
The goal today is pretty simple.
First is to lay
understand the steps
in the LCA, exactly what is
the methodology, how it's used,
the specific steps in
it and what they mean,
what goes into each of them.
But really, what we're
also going to spend time on
is understanding
the decisions that
go into that, using the hand
dryer study as an example
to go through and
understand how you link all
these different steps together,
what it means in understanding
the decisions that you have
to make as a person doing this
or as a company, in terms
of setting the boundary,
understanding what your goal
is, and all the uncertainty that
goes along with
all the decisions
and assumptions that you
have to make along the way.
Last time when we were talking
about carbon footprinting,
we were talking really
about things that
go on at the corporate level.
Within the boundary is
essentially drawn around
your organization.
We talked about how you
could use those internally,
doing things like trying to
evaluate different departments
in your organization,
tracking your performance,
setting up some kind
of internal metrics.
All the standard
sort of things you
would do for financial cost,
quality, sustainability, really
just one extension of that.
But also talking about
its relation to external,
you're publishing a
corporate CSR report,
participating in programs like
the Carbon Disclosure Project,
reporting to regulators,
investors, et cetera.
And one of the things
we've talked about
was the difficulty in
comparing between organizations
that might be doing
different activities.
Even though they operate
in the same business space,
they might produce some
of the same products,
it's very difficult to
compare two organizations
based on their organizational
level reporting,
because they might control
different aspects of the supply
chain.
They may do different
things, even if they're
producing the same products.
Today we're going to talk
about the lower section here,
which is how we do a product
or a supply chain level
comparison.
And some of the same
ideas still apply,
that there might be
reasons to do this
both internally and externally.
Internally, right,
trying to understand
where in the supply chain
your environmental impact is.
What are the things you
might have control over
that you might be
willing to-- that you
might be looking to change.
Exploring, especially
differences
in the design or
changes that you might
make to reduce those impacts.
But also it has an external
components as well,
namely around
things like product
labeling or making environmental
claims about your product.
Trying to convince
consumers or your customers
that your product is better than
ones that are on the market.
And again, there's going to be
some slight differences that
go on between what
you're trying to do
and how you might go about it.
So with that, we'll start off
talking about this hand dryer
study, and then go through
the bits and pieces of it
individually.
This really is
getting into-- it's
a pretty good example
of something that
gets at the fundamental
questions of how
you compare different
products and different things.
In this case, we
don't really care
much about who owns which piece
of each of these products.
We're looking at the product as
a whole from beginning to end
and trying to come up with
a way of comparing them.
This is the result from
some of the material that
came out of the
publication of this study.
But it requires a different
type of analysis and sort
of a different level of work.
Has anybody in here done a
life cycle assessment before?
What kind of product,
or what did you look at?
AUDIENCE: I used to
work at a company that
made seafood products, and we
looked at three of our SKUs
that we made for Walmart.
They asked us to specifically
do a life cycle assessment
on three different
products of theirs.
PROFESSOR: Just to
understand what the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, not
of a larger, they
were working with us and
numerous other companies,
but they were trying to get
a sense of what the larger
impact of individual
items that they carried
was in different departments
over the course of the weeks.
PROFESSOR: Did you actually
do the-- were you responsible
for sort of--
AUDIENCE: I did a large
portion of the data collection
for the stuff we were most
directly responsible for.
It was kind of
broken into chunks,
so a major part
was packaging, then
there was the food that
went in the packaging.
And so I was working with
all the different groups who
knew the most about
those respective portions
to then draw the data from them
and put it together cohesively.
PROFESSOR: How
about anybody else?
Anybody read previous
studies like this before,
or seen anything
like this before?
AUDIENCE: I actually read this
one for when we were working
on the [? S-Lab ?] project.
And I really wanted
some guidance
on the choice of materials.
So they said LCA, but
when we got down to it,
it was actually
just the materials,
so it was not the
whole assessment.
PROFESSOR: What were
some of your impressions
about it after
reading through this?
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was strange of them
in the beginning to say
that they were going
to do a full life cycle
assessment including
transportation costs, and
then two sentences later they
said they were going to
ignore the entire supply chain
and just focus on doing
an apples to apples
comparison of the performance.
And they sort of black
box all of the dryers
into the same sort
of process in China.
And I thought we weren't
necessarily getting
who, maybe, was the real
champion between Dyson
and Excel.
Because if perhaps
one of them happens
to have manufacturing
in the United States,
then they're getting
a large transportation
cost lumped into the cycle
that maybe doesn't exist.
So I don't really know why
they decided to go that route.
It seems like they went
through all the machinations
for the paper towels, so
it wouldn't have been maybe
that difficult to get it
for the other companies
as well, so that they actually
did the real full life cycle.
Because otherwise,
it seems like they
should have collapsed
the scope if they only
wanted to do performance,
and leave the upstream part
of the supply chain out of it.
PROFESSOR: So right, they didn't
really ignore the supply chain,
they more just standardized
it, in a sense.
Because they did include all
of those things that go on,
but they didn't model
the exact supply chain
that each specific
product might have taken.
So what was the reason for that?
They mentioned why
they did it in there.
AUDIENCE: They said
they wanted to put them
all on equal footing as
part of the supply chain,
but it seems like
not putting them
on equal footing is sort of
the purpose of the life cycle,
to see who actually
has the better process.
AUDIENCE: It actually
didn't matter.
They had a figure that explained
if all these different devices
were manufactured in
Malaysia, US, or China,
there's very little
difference across them.
PROFESSOR: Right.
We'll talk about that, because
as we read through there,
there's a lot of assumptions
that they had to make going on.
So what might have
been one of the reasons
they had to make that assumption
about the supply chain,
about taking this.
AUDIENCE: They just might not
have had the data available
and they determined that they
could spend a year trying
to find the data,
but in the end,
it wouldn't have
made a difference
and they wanted to
go through the study
and finish it anyways.
PROFESSOR: Right.
In essence, that if you didn't
have all the information
for all of the products,
then you really
had two choices which
was to perhaps go
spend the time trying
to identify everything,
the exact path that
all of those products
took in their supply chain.
The other would be to
try to ignore that piece
and put them on a sort
of standardized setting
to do the comparison with,
and then come back later
and test some of
those assumptions.
And that was sort
of the approach
that they took with this one.
What were some of the
other areas that stood out?
AUDIENCE: The
sensitivity analyses
were the majority of the paper.
PROFESSOR: The paper
itself was like 25 pages,
and then there was like 80
pages of sensitivity analysis
and whatnot at the end.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
there were a lot
of assumptions in understanding
which of the assumptions
had more risk.
What I was really struck
by, too, was the fact
that so much of
the data was coming
from either the
companies themselves
or from other studies.
And there was a point at
the end of the paper that
said they didn't have
access to the writers,
authors, or practitioners
who prepared those studies.
So I think that the gap,
they made assumptions
made on gaps of information,
but even the information
that they do have I
called into question.
I [? didn't believe ?]
the accuracy of it.
PROFESSOR: So access
to data was something
that came up a number of times.
You saw there are a
number of previous studies
that have been
done, and you kept
probably noticing the references
throughout the document
of every time that there's some
assumption or some play made.
And most of them were
being traced back
to previous studies that
had been done before.
AUDIENCE: Even if you
had access to data,
the thing also is that data
changes and you get updates,
and you get more data.
So I thought that the LSA
was true at some point,
but it's also made very quickly.
PROFESSOR: I'm going
to say it's static.
It's a snapshot
of a point in time
of a specific configuration
of the supply chain analysis.
AUDIENCE: My frustration with
it was the single most important
variable when it's how long
people take to dry their hands
or how many paper
towels they use,
and they had no
real data on that.
It was just completely made
up, because you can't really
get that kind of data,
because you can't put cameras
in a bathroom, and you
can't put someone in there
without affecting
their behaviors.
PROFESSOR: The joke
that they had--
the study authors were here
at MIT in the material systems
labs-- is that they
thought about going out
to the airport and
just sort of standing
in the bathroom with a
notepad tracking people,
but figured that might get them
thrown out by security pretty
quickly.
In some sense, this comes back
to the idea of access to data.
You're making these assumptions
because you lack the data
that, if you had gone through
and done some of the studies
and things like that-- actually
observed people-- you might
understand how exactly it is,
what is the average hand drying
time, things like that.
AUDIENCE: They talked about the
lifetime of the dryer, which
they had as five
years, and thought
that seemed kind of low.
It seems like five
years would be
pretty frequent for a building
manager to change out dryers.
Is that time until
it breaks or is
that the time until they
recommended [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Anybody know
why they chose five years?
AUDIENCE: Warranty.
PROFESSOR: That's
what the warranty is.
AUDIENCE: But how many people--
PROFESSOR: Throw it out
if it's working fine.
I'm going to Juan,
this goes back
to your first point
about what they chose.
The configuration of the supply
chain was important, right.
And this goes back to, if
we're taking a static snapshot
of something that all the
different permutations and all
the different combinations
might be difficult to do,
so you have to start
making some judgments
about the configuration
of the supply chain.
And so they did that, in
this case, by assuming they
all came from China.
Except for the towels,
which came from the US,
because that's sort of
the industry standard.
That's the second one, these
are related to each other.
As you start
digging into it, you
start running into
all these areas
that you could do
things differently,
and there's sort of all these
different variables that
go into it.
At some point, you
have to start making
some assumptions
and some limitations
to try to do better on it.
Did any of you think
any of these-- I mean,
they did some
sensitivity analysis,
but which ones do you
think would significantly
have affected the outcome?
Or were there any?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that usage data, too,
was just a huge factor, because
if you looked at the outputs.
The overall ranking
of the product
was so largely driven
by what was said,
was estimated to be your usage.
That was one of the least
effectively tracked, or easily
quantifiable metrics.
So to me, that was just
sort of [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Going
along those lines,
I think that it was
the number of papers,
or the mass of the papers
that is used for one usage.
So that had a significant
impact on how big
of a GWP for the
paper towels have
compared to all the others.
So that was a big
assumption, too.
They made some big assumptions
on the hand dryers,
but also on the paper towels.
PROFESSOR: And in
some sense, this
gets back to--
Different bathrooms
have different types
of paper towels,
and so identifying
one paper towel
that you're going to choose
to be representative of
can be quite difficult to do.
AUDIENCE: I [? think also ?]
throwing out
the electric grid assumptions
[INAUDIBLE] in use,
and they had some pretty big
impacts on the manufacturing
for the paper towels.
So the paper towels, if they
weren't made in the United
States and they weren't
made on the average,
that could have a huge impact.
Likewise the usage, depending
on where it was being used,
[INAUDIBLE] would have a big
impact on the electric dryers.
PROFESSOR: So if
you were Xlerator
which came in probably
as the most similar,
in terms of products that
it would be competing with.
I don't know if you've used the
Xlerator dryer before, but just
really powerful
heated air coming out.
A little bit different setup.
But it generally,
and the results
showed us the second best after
the Dyson one, but probably
their direct competitor.
So what would your response
be if you were Xlerator
and you saw Dyson sort
of promoting this study?
AUDIENCE: [? I think I'd say ?]
Xlerator was made in the US
and Dyson was made in Malaysia,
so you could point out that
Dyson doesn't have to be--
Dyson using the [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] the US electric grid
for [? manual ?] [INAUDIBLE]
and also have to ship the
products across the ocean.
PROFESSOR: That's a big
part of the marketing,
they need to have
a made in the US
certified, whatever that
means, on their webpage.
AUDIENCE: Also for Xlerator,
the measured versus
reported drying times
were really different.
For Dyson they were
exactly the same,
it was almost
double for Xlerator.
So they may want to get control
of how much time they think
people are spending and
maybe make their machines
a little bit more efficient.
Because if they were to go to
12 seconds, which is lower,
the difference between Dyson
and Xlerator wasn't that big.
But when you went
with the 20-- I
think it was 20
seconds-- that's where
the difference was more severe.
PROFESSOR: So where did that
measured drying time come from?
AUDIENCE: Because they
looked for the measure,
they were following the NSF
standards of 0.1 gram of water
on the hands when you
dry it on a towel.
But in [INAUDIBLE] I mean,
it's really perceptions.
The user doesn't actually
measure 0.1 grams of water
on my hand, you'd better
stop using the dryer.
It's really a perception issue.
PROFESSOR: We had that
NSF protocol, all right.
This is not National
Science Foundation,
it's National Standards
or International Standards
Institute, something like that.
They have standards for a lot
of things, and in this case,
it's how do you
define dry hands.
So it's whatever it was, 0.01
grams of moisture per whatever
is how they defined it.
So the idea would be that if you
were trying to objectively make
some claim about how long
it takes to dry the hands,
that might be one way to do it.
Who actually did the
testing for that, though?
AUDIENCE: It was some study
at University of Florida.
I don't really know how they
came up with those numbers.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I think, actually,
Dyson reported it.
So it was coming from
a document that Dyson
had claiming that somebody
had done this test
and come up with it.
So you see, we're
starting to get this paper
trail going back and figuring
out that so much of the study
was dependent on this value,
and that the person reporting
these values is
essentially Dyson,
who's making the claim
that it came from.
Even though we have sort of
a standard that makes sense
in terms of, OK, we're going
to try to find some way
to do this objectively.
It still would definitely leave
some room open for Xlerator
to probably take
some issues with it.
AUDIENCE: If Xlerator was really
concerned about the results
of the study, too-- and
something I've never noticed
using one of the
Airblades, they said
that it has a digital motor,
so it has no spin down time,
so they didn't credit the Dyson
with any 1.5 seconds spin down.
Whereas the Xlerator was
doing it out 3 over 750 watts,
and assume 750 watts, which
adds up over the 350,000 uses.
So I guess if they wanted
to borrow that idea
and get rid of some
energy consumption,
they could do that.
PROFESSOR: So if you
were Xlerator you'd seen,
you read this study, and
wanted to respond to that,
what might you go
do differently?
AUDIENCE: One, you might
commission your own study.
Since this was
commissioned by Dyson.
That's a pretty
big starting point.
Dyson commissioned-- not to
say that the researchers at MIT
weren't as objective as
possible-- but as we noted,
there was a good deal of
data that the study was
dependent on that
came from Dyson
and Dyson then commissioned
the study with it.
So if I'm Xlerator, I'd probably
like to have a say in that
as well.
PROFESSOR: Right, so that
was one of the other issues
with the data access, right.
Because Dyson was
behind this, they
supplied the bill of
materials and they
supplied all of the data
about the factory and things
like that, whereas all
the other products,
they had to make use of
publicly available information.
So they didn't have access
to that inside information.
So if you were Xlerator and saw
this, and disagreed with it,
you could commission
your own study.
You could now make
use of the fact
that you know about
your supply chain,
and you could start actually
going and doing the details.
You could go through the
fact that you're actually
made in the US,
and you might want
to redo the study
under that assumption.
That you're going look at
it with your specific supply
chain, no longer
considering, say,
a generic's supply
chain from China.
So what would you do
to get around this?
Because that is still
sort of the crux of it,
was that you both claim
similar drying times,
but they're saying
that in practice, yours
is actually worse.
AUDIENCE: I don't know, it
just depends on [INAUDIBLE]
here's what they did.
Putting cameras or
individuals in bathrooms,
but potentially building
in some sort of chip that
enables you to see what
actual times are for drying,
and then that could
work in your favor.
PROFESSOR: I might go out
and actually redo this study
that Dyson was reporting.
If I use this NSF study, to
go in and at least verify
that it really does
take my machine
30 seconds versus their 12
seconds or something like that.
So at MIT, if you wanted
to do study of figuring out
how long people
actually dried it,
you'd have to go through
the human subject ethics
board and all of that.
So you might have
trouble actually
getting a study through where
you actually went out and tried
to observe it.
But you could at
least try to reduce
some of that uncertainty that
comes in the measurement,
since it's unfavorable to
you and not really much hard
information out there about it.
So you might want to commission,
say, an outside source
to come in and
repeat that testing,
and see if they really got it.
In terms of what they're
actually doing-- so
they actually have commissioned
a study to respond,
to follow up on this.
Because nobody's
ever going to be
happy with all the
assumptions that
go on in one of these,
especially when they turn out
to be-- if you look at
two of these big ones
that are certainly unfavorable
to Xlerator, probably.
When you look at
them it makes sense
that maybe you would want to
come back in and revisit this
to try to make sure
that the assumptions
that your competitor is
making that are unfavorable
to you actually are
grounded in reality,
or don't necessarily
make a difference
in the final outcome.
But you probably don't
want them releasing
a study that says
this is your product
and it's worse for
the environment,
it takes longer
to dry, et cetera,
without at least being prepared
with some sort of follow up
to dispute that, other
than to just ignore it
or claim that there's
problems with it.
You'd like to be
able to come back
with some sort of response
that's grounded in some data
or have some facts for it.
We're going to walk through
this a little bit more in depth
in terms of looking at it within
the scope of the methodology
of life cycle assessment.
But to start off with, just
what is life cycle assessment.
And that's a good
question to ask,
because it took some
time for the industry
itself to figure out
what exactly it was.
But there are a set
of ISO standards
that I think were produced in
the 1997, the first version.
Essentially it says this.
LCA is a technique for
assessing environmental aspects
and potential impacts
with a product by first,
compiling an inventory of
the inputs and outputs.
So tracking, what's coming in
and out of the environment.
Second, evaluating the
potential impacts associated
with the inputs and outputs.
So figuring out,
now I know what I'm
emitting to the air, what I'm
taking out of the environment,
actually figuring out
what those impacts are.
And one of the
key points here is
that it specifically mentions
the potential environmental
impacts.
Because some of
these studies are
going to be forward looking.
Trying to figure
out what happens
when we make a change as opposed
to some of these studies that
are looking backwards
and trying to figure out
what the actual impact is.
So that's a big one, is
that a lot of times, we
don't necessarily know what the
exact environmental impact is.
We're trying to forecast ahead
of time what it's going to be.
And finally,
interpreting the results
in the inventory analysis and
impact assessment in relation
to the objectives of the study.
So the big thing about this
is that it's sort of fluid,
in terms of what an LCA is.
Because you start off with
creating some kind of objective
of what you want to do with the
study, and all of the results
that you generate are going
to be interpreted back
in terms of that scope and that
goal that you started with.
Some of the important
things to remember
is that it takes
a life cycle view
of the product, so raw
materials all the way
through to end of life.
So to cradle to grave
is typically the way
that would be talked about.
And while it specifically
mentions products,
it can be mentioned
for services as well.
So we can think of the
hand drying example.
It's not necessarily
comparing products,
it's more comparing a
service, that of drying hands.
LCA generally
credited to Coca Cola
as being the first person to
develop this back in 1969, when
they commissioned
a study that would
look at the environmental impact
of using cans or glass bottles.
So this is when they were first
thinking about going to cans,
and they were trying to
understand not just all
the economic and
supply chain impact,
but they wanted to consider the
environmental impacts as well.
They commissioned a study and
actually hired some researchers
to do it, and
essentially they came up
with what would eventually
become life cycle assessment,
in terms of quantifying
that environmental impact
in some manner by looking
at the inputs and outputs.
So that was in 1969.
It started to gain
attention in the '70s.
There were other efforts
going on in this area,
especially in Europe
with the energy crisis.
There was a lot more
concern about things
like how much energy
products were using,
services, about what
it was going to mean.
As that started to
fade away-- the energy
crisis-- in the '80s, it
became a little bit more
known for companies making
environmental claims
about their products, so
trying to use it in advertising
and things like that.
It gave rise to what they
referred to as hired gun
studies.
Which is basically, as we saw,
there's a lot of assumptions
and a lot of
questionable assumptions,
at times, that go into
doing one of these studies.
And what they were
finding is that there
are companies out there
that you would hire them
and they would construct
a study in such a way
that it said basically
whatever you wanted, reaching
the point that 11 state attorney
generals issued guidelines
saying that you couldn't use
life cycle assessment to make
a claim or a comparative claim
about the environmental impact
of your product in
an advertisement,
until LCA became standardized.
Until a uniform
methodology was developed.
So that sort of
kicked it into gear
of getting different companies,
different organizations
together to try to iron out
what exactly a life cycle
assessment was going to be.
SETAC was probably
the leading group,
and then it's something
like the something
environmental toxicity
and chemistry,
society for environmental
toxicity in chemistry, I think.
Something like that.
So it's generally
chemists, people
that study ecotoxicology,
things like that,
getting together and creating
working groups, generally
of academics and practitioners,
trying to come up
with a uniform methodology
that can be used for life cycle
assessment.
And eventually this developed
into some standards from ISO.
14040 is the main
one, but there are
about four or five
different offshoots
from that that cover
different aspects of it,
from the guidelines for how you
do it, to how you would use it,
to making claims, or
how you would use it
for putting labels on products.
So it's sort of grown quite
a bit from those beginnings.
So essentially, the
methodology that they developed
is going to consist
of four stages.
The first of which is the
goal and scope definition.
Which is comprised of
a couple of things,
namely deciding what
it is you're analyzing,
looking at what the scope of the
system is under consideration,
identifying what falls
within your system boundary.
The second step is referred
to as the inventory analysis.
This is where you're
identifying and quantifying
all the things that
come in, raw materials
that are coming in
from the environment,
all the emissions that are
going back out, whether it's
to air or water or land.
Other products that you might
be using, all of the inputs.
And essentially creating
an inventory of those,
identifying how much there are.
The third step is
the impact analysis.
This is where we go
from the inventory,
from identifying
everything that's going in,
to figuring out what exactly the
environmental impact from that
is going to be, and what
methodology is used to do that.
And then finally,
as we talked about,
interpretation is
the fourth step.
So we want to go
back and, after we've
set the goal of the study--
identified the scope
and gone through and quantified
the environmental impact-- how
do we take these results
and relate them back
all the things we set out
from the beginning that
were our goals.
So if we start off with the
goal and scope definition,
right, the first thing
is to decide the product
you're going to be studying and
what the purpose of the study
is.
And that includes three points.
What is the intended application
of the study, so what
are you trying to do with it.
What's your reason
for carrying it out.
And third, for whom are the
results going to be used.
So if we look at the study
that we looked at today,
you'll notice when the study
is laid out, as you read it,
it was actually laid out in
sections that followed along
from our four step.
Let's talk about the
product to be studied
and the purpose of the study.
What did they claim were
the reasons for doing this?
First off, what was the
product that was being studied?
AUDIENCE: A dry set of hands.
PROFESSOR: So it's
a Dyson Airblade
and it's not a paper towel.
What they set up was a
per pair of dried hands.
So this is what we would refer
to as the functional unit.
This is actually what
we're going to study,
and everything that's
done throughout the study
is in terms of this.
So this is going to be
our unit of analysis,
it's going to be how
we're going to compare
all of these different options.
And what did they say
the intended application
of the study was?
What were they trying to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
dry hands [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So they
actually had two uses.
What was the target
audience for this?
AUDIENCE: [? The engineer. ?]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if we look at
in terms of this,
one group of people that
the results were for
were the Dyson engineers.
They wanted to go
through and understand
where were the impact--
what was the reason,
it was to identify the impacts
associated with the Airblade
so that the engineers
could take a look at that
and start figuring
out ways to reduce it.
What was the other purpose?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
environmental impacts.
PROFESSOR: Related to that.
So if all I wanted to do was
identify for my engineers
where the impacts
of the Airblade is,
would I need to consider
paper towels and the Xlerator
and things like that?
No.
So that's our second
reason, was comparative.
They wanted to go
through and say
here's the environmental
impact associated
with a dry pair of hands
when you use the Airblade,
and here it is when
you associated it
with one of the other
products under consideration.
So they actually
had the Airblade.
What else did they study?
The Xlerator.
AUDIENCE: Recycled paper towels.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so they had
two versions of the paper towel.
And they had two versions
of the Airblade, too.
The aluminum and the plastic.
AUDIENCE: Standard, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, standard.
Cotton Roll towels.
So this gets back to our
choice of a functional
unit was the dry pair of
hands, so this gives us
the basis that we're going
to do these comparisons on.
But in terms of the goal
and scope, that's important,
because if I just wanted to
use something internally, then
I would never go to the trouble.
There's no need to go to all of
the trouble to do all of this.
The big thing that
drove a lot of this
is the idea that it's
going to be comparative.
That they actually want to
make a comparison between what
happens when you use the
Airblade between when you use
some of these other systems.
And it's going to come back
because once they did this,
then they had to start making
a lot of assumptions about how
these other systems work,
since they didn't necessarily
have the data to that.
And then because you're
doing that comparison,
you sort of-- part
of it is they're
going to make this
available externally.
They've said that
part of it might be
to use this for making claims.
And so once you've
decided that you're
going to start using
it for public claims,
you definitely want to be
a little bit more rigorous
in your application
and your approach.
Because as soon as you publish
this and start making claims
that X and all of
the other companies
are going to look at
this and think, well,
why didn't you do
this, why this.
So this sort of
drives a lot of what
goes on in the next few steps.
That by doing this, now we've
expanded the scope of our study
from just looking at
my supply chain, which
I have pretty good
visibility to,
to starting to look at a lot
of different other products.
And this brings a lot of
extra complexity to it,
because I have a number
of different studies.
And if each of these has
different configurations
or different
assumptions that I make,
the complexity starts
really blowing up.
System boundary.
What did they choose
for the system boundary?
AUDIENCE: They chose not to
include things like maintenance
or transportation
[INAUDIBLE] So they
had to make a lot of assumptions
[? around ?] the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So they start off
by saying this is a life cycle
assessment.
So we're going to
do cradle to grave.
And you can think about
that, that idea that you're
doing cradle to grave
creates a lot of problems,
because they mentioned there's
how many different screws
in the Airblade?
And you think that
now you need to trace
each of these little parts all
the way up through their supply
chain.
So they started making
some definitions
about where they were going to
sort of consider things outside
of the system boundary.
So there are a couple of
issues that go into that.
So one was cut off rules.
So what did they use
as a cut off rule?
AUDIENCE: 1%, if it's
less than 1% in effect
then they didn't include it.
PROFESSOR: Right,
and so this creates--
what's the issue here.
If it had less than 1%
of the total impact,
they would exclude it.
What's the issue with
using this as a rule?
AUDIENCE: Number of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's part of it.
How do you know when
something only contributes
1% of the total impact?
It's like a chicken
and the egg problem.
If you've quantified to
identify that it's less than 1%
of the impact, why
wouldn't you include it.
What they have actually done
is for all those little things,
they've done some basically
back of the envelope
or some other type of
high level estimate
to try to figure
out what they are,
without going to the
trouble of digging
down deep into the level of it
to try to identify what it was.
They mentioned some
of the other, right?
They were using a
lot of information
from other previous
studies, they
mentioned some of
the other rules
that some of the other
studies had used.
Remember what some
of those were?
AUDIENCE: Also on
that, didn't they
limit it to no more than
like 5% of the total product
on this 1% assumption
so they couldn't
say every screw didn't matter.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we do any individual
process that was less than 1%,
and in total, everything that I
excluded had to be less than 5%
of the total.
These are pretty common rules.
So you can think about this is
if you had a bunch of things
that were less than 1%, but then
you estimated the total impact,
they were only covering 90%.
So you would just start
adding more and more of those
back into the system boundary
until you hit that 95% percent
point.
Some of the other studies
used a slightly different rule
than the impact.
So some of them did this
based on physical quantities.
So anything that was
less than 1% of the mass,
I think one of the
studies, was excluded.
This tends to be easier,
because you don't actually
have to go to the trouble of
estimating what the impact is.
You can start saying,
well, I'm just
going to exclude all of the
tiny little things that go.
But you're making an
assumption that those
don't contribute big, right.
So if it's got-- I don't
know, some uranium in it
or something else
that's radioactive,
that may have a very high impact
in terms of certain categories
even if they don't contribute
much the overall weight.
So generally, this
would be preferred.
We would like to make a ballpark
estimate of what the impact is
and then go through and
exclude based on that
rather than basically
just using one
of these physical quantities.
There were some other
things that they cut out
from the system boundary.
AUDIENCE: Something about
excluding raw materials
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So I think
they included that,
or they should have, at least.
I think it was
mentioned earlier.
We had capital goods,
were not included.
This is also a fairly
common exclusion.
Things that have a multiple year
lifetime, not to include those.
You could include
in the same way
that, when they
made the decision
to do a dry pair of hands, they
had to start making assumptions
about the lifetime of the
product, how many uses
it was going to get made.
And then they allocated
a portion of that
to the life cycle.
They included things like
the bins and the liners
they were using for paper
towels and things like that.
You could include capital goods.
You'd have to start
making assumptions
about how many years it existed,
how many products it read.
If you were to include the
trucks or the ships that
move the goods, how
many trips a year
does it make, how many
containers does it move.
You could start doing that.
They tend to be pretty low.
If you're including
the transportation
piece of the ocean,
so you're capturing
all of the fuel
that's being burned,
but you're just
not capturing what
goes into building the ship.
So that's another one
that's a pretty common one.
So they mentioned in
the study that some
of the studies they used had
excluded the capital goods,
and so they chose to exclude
capital goods in this as
well in order to maintain
that consistency.
So in this case, they
might have otherwise
chosen to include those.
But because they were
relying on past data,
they went ahead and
included them anyway.
What about with
the paper towels?
This was specifically one
of the issues that they had.
AUDIENCE: Whether
or not to include
the environmental impact
of previous recycling.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
this is another big one.
Specifically, what was it
about this type of recycling
that was difficult?
Remember what the term
they used for it was?
Open loop.
So this is the problem
with things like paper,
is that something that is
a paper towel, if you were
to collect it and
recycle it, usually
the strength of the paper you
get from the recycled fiber
is not as strong as it
was when it started.
So if it started off as a paper
towel when you recycled it,
it's usually no longer strong
enough to be a paper towel.
So it might get made into
toilet paper, or newsprint,
or whatever else is
on down the line.
You get into this situation
where you have the product,
and you recycle
it, and then it's
going to go get turned into
some other product that
has its own life cycle,
and it's going through.
As opposed to a
closed loop recycling,
that product would just
get turned right back
into an input.
And if I were to do that, then
I can draw my system boundary
around this, and I don't
have to worry about it,
because it will get included
in this system boundary.
But when I'm doing
this, I start getting
into multiple different
types of products.
This is a problem
because the input--
when it mentioned they had
the two types of paper towels.
Some were made
from virgin fibers
and some were made
from recycled fibers.
If it's made from
a recycled fiber,
it had its whole life cycle
before it became a paper towel.
When it was maybe copy paper,
or something similar to that.
That usually means
you're going to have
to make some decision about
where to draw the line,
in terms of how
far we go chasing
all of these other products that
it might have been turned into.
So, again, the goal--
this comes directly
from what they
wrote in the report.
Compare the environmental
impact of hand drying systems.
Evaluate how the impact under
different manufacturing and use
scenarios.
So this is part of it, is that
they, rather than consider it
within the context
of just one scenario,
they want to try a couple
of those scenarios.
This related back
to the assumptions
that they had to make.
Two, identify impact
drivers and ways
to target those with the idea
to inform product decisions.
We mentioned this
comparative assertion,
so this is sort of
the important one,
because that lets us
know this is going
to go to an external audience.
This brings its own
set of requirements.
So if you're going
to use something
for comparative assertions,
the ISO standards
generally require you to have
a third party evaluation of it.
So if you look through
in one of the appendices,
they mentioned the results
of their third party,
essentially, review of it.
And so they had a
panel of three experts
go through and review the
initial draft of the life cycle
assessment study, and
then they had to go back,
and usually you
get critical-- it's
like submitting
something for peer
review at an academic
journal or something similar,
where you would
get back comments
about what you
might want to change
and what you might want to do.
So once you start making some
of these selections upfront
about the goal of
your study, that's
going to drive
extra requirements
and make some
complications for what
you need to do down the road.
Finally, they mentioned
internal and external audiences.
With the goal, the big
thing to keep track of
is, there's really two types of
life cycle assessment studies
and they go by different names.
Attributional, first
consequential is one of them.
One I've heard is
accounting based,
that would be the attributional.
And this would be
change oriented.
Really, these are little
diagrams that somebody created
that are useful to think of it.
The attributional one,
which is what they've
done in this paper, is
essentially taking a system
and trying to figure out
what portion of that system's
environmental impact is related
to whatever you're looking at.
So it's taking a static
snapshot of something
and trying to attribute the
various environmental impact
to your product.
The consequential,
the change oriented,
is going to take
a system and it's
going to try to model what
happens when you make changes
to it.
So the big thing of that
is that it's not static.
The picture's going to change.
You might reduce impact
in certain areas,
but it might increase
it in other areas.
And so this attributional
style is generally
things that are
backwards looking,
whether it be estimating the
environmental impact of one
of your products.
If you wanted to, say,
do a carbon label,
or to meet some certain
standard to get an eco label.
To estimate the environmental
impacts of different systems
as they are now,
is the big thing.
The consequential is
going to look at what
happens when we make a change.
So usually what this means
is that could involve
very big changes in the system.
That if you make
certain decisions,
they're going to impact.
That things might
look this way now,
if I look at just the system
as it is, but say my demand is
starting to increase
and I start to have
to start making different
changes, that could
shift the way it would be.
So one good example of
this would be looking
at, say, the impact of ethanol.
If you look at US
policy on ethanol.
If you just look at
a static snapshot
of where we're at right now,
or the way it exists right now.
You'd look at the life cycle
for, say, corn ethanol,
and you measure its
environmental impact.
And then you compare
that to, say,
what it takes to produce
gasoline or diesel fuel,
and you come up with an
environmental impact.
And so that generally
would tell you
the ethanol is slightly better
on, say, a greenhouse gas
perspective.
But when you start
looking at what
happens when you start
making big shifts,
as we start converting
crop land from other uses
in order to turn it into
corn, in order to turn that
into ethanol, you start
getting a cascade of change
as they go on.
So in the case of the US, we've
switched a lot of farmland
over to corn, and
so that has left
a gap in wheat and soybeans
and other crops that used
to grow on land that were corn.
So now we don't have as much
to export to other countries.
So those countries have to
convert some of their land
to uses to grow, to make
up for our wheat shortage.
And so then they may end
up clearing rain forest
or some other sort
of bad impact,
in order to turn that into
land to grow these crops on.
So once you start looking at
this cascade of system effects,
people think that ethanol
is no longer preferable.
That once you include the
indirect effects, it's better.
So in that case,
that's what happened
when you start looking forward.
Looking at what happens when I
start to make a change to this.
And so if you look at
the characteristics
of these different
types of systems,
they're going to
have differences
in what you're going to do.
Part of that is the
choice of data, right.
These we tend to
based on average data,
because we look at the average
electricity grid in the US.
You're usually not making,
and we're not looking at,
something that creates
enough change in the system
to really worry about
whether it's impacting things
at the margins.
But once you start looking
at energy policy or some
of these big areas, if
you start looking at,
what if we were to shift a
significant portion of steel
production to aluminum
production, which might be much
more electricity intensive.
Then we start needing
more power plants.
Maybe those new power
plants come online,
are gas powered as
opposed to coal fired,
and so the actual electricity
and the actual emissions impact
is less than if you looked
at the average of the grid.
So these are the ideas
between what type of study
are you looking at.
It's going to drive
some of these choices
and where you get the data,
what the system boundary is.
One of the nice things about
doing a change oriented
LCA is that if I have
things that didn't change--
I'm comparing two systems,
a before and after,
and I have pieces of it
that didn't change at all,
I can ignore those pieces.
Because they're not
going to affect.
I'm just looking at the
changes that happened,
so I can sort of exclude all of
those from the system boundary.
Whereas with this
type of assessment,
where I have to trace everything
all the way up and back,
I have to make sure that it's
fully complete to make sure
that I'm really getting
that share of the emissions.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the power grids.
Is there, to your
knowledge, any effort
to track specifically
which type of power
is being used at the
point in question?
For example, if something's
made in Pennsylvania
it's probably coal, but
if it's made in Idaho,
it's almost
exclusively hydraulic.
Anyone ever account for that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you can definitely
get at that level.
Even in things like the
greenhouse gas protocol
when we were talking about
corporate level ones.
If you go and look at
the tools that they
have for measuring the
impact of electricity,
you can get regional
specific factors.
One thing to remember with
electricity, it's on the grid.
So even though you may
locally be supplied
by a nuclear or
coal plant, you're
part of, usually,
a regional grid.
So they tend to break it out
into inter-regional ones.
But you can get further
down emissions factors
and start looking.
We did a study with
Chiquita looking at bananas.
And so for that, we
went-- part of that
is that they're grown in
Central and South America.
So you can go out and look
at the different electricity
factors at a
country level there,
and they can make quite
a bit of difference.
There are, definitely.
One, a lot of people of
people already do that.
Two is that you tend to
be able to model that
by looking at the
percentage mix of coal
versus nuclear
versus gas that might
be used in any specific area.
It's a really
tricky question when
you start thinking
about what happens
as I start to change
things, because then you
get into where's
the power going to,
which plants come online
as demand starts to surge,
and things like that.
But that's definitely an
area that people look at.
Usually the big question is
whether-- if you looked at,
what if I did some
small change where,
say, I moved my corporate
offices from one location
to another.
You probably wouldn't want
to use the marginal data
on electricity if you move
from one region to the other,
because you're not
really large enough
to have an effect on what's
going on with the grid
at that sort of level.
So maybe it's better off to
stick with averages and things
like that.
So there's some grey area
in there in determining when
it's right to use which factor.
We've covered this,
the functional unit
is a pair of dried hands.
Once you've made that, it
makes sense because as we saw,
it's in the use where
the impact comes from.
So the question becomes,
you don't really
want to compare an Airblade
versus an Xlerator.
You want to compare what
happens over the use.
And definitely, when
you start including
things that are not a one
to one correspondence--
comparing paper towels
versus an Airblade,
you want to put them on a unit
of analysis that makes sense.
But once you start
doing that, you
start getting other-- right.
So that's one of the things you
decide up front, and then that
creates a cascade of
decisions about what you're
going to have to do later on.
Amongst that, making
assumptions about the length.
How many hands get dried,
the lifespan of it.
All the ancillary and secondary
products to go along with it.
So it's the kind of thing
you want to decide upfront,
because it creates consequences
for what you do down the line.
And that's why it's usually
one of the first things
that you'll do in the study.
Scope, we had seven
different systems.
Cradle to grave.
They mention this
within there, that they
are including packaging.
So the cardboard that they
come in, or the plastic
wrap when it's there, and the
bins and liners and dispensers.
So you want to be
clear when you're
setting the scope about
what things you're including
and what not.
So they include the
packaging, but they
don't include the pallets
that they get shipped on,
things like that.
Capital goods, et cetera.
And with the system boundary.
We covered some of the
allocation, what it means.
So you had the end of
life we talked about.
Co-products, if you have
a manufacturing plant
or some other facility
that's producing
a number of different
goods, you usually
are going to run into that
same allocation problem
where you're going
to have to figure out
some way of apportioning the
impacts of the production
process to the different
products that come out.
And again, there's
various rules for that.
Usually they're going to
be simple things like mass,
energy, or economic impact.
One example in the
textbook I have
is a chicken processing plant.
You're taking in
chickens and you're
producing breasts,
thighs, wings,
all of these different products.
You can divide up
the impact of what
it takes to produce a
chicken, to raise it,
to give it feed, all of that.
But at the end, you have
all of these different types
of products that all come
from that same input,
and then figure
out how to divide
those impacts amongst the
different products that
are coming out.
So mass or energy would
be one way to do it.
I just weigh the
different products
and I'll assign them
each share of that burden
based on their weight.
But again, this may work
well for some things,
but not for others.
Especially when you have some
products that are coming out
that are very high value.
Since those tend to drive
the decisions that you make.
So maybe you want to do it on
the economic basis instead,
which is to say, I'm going
to portion my impacts based
on the share of the value that
each of these items generate.
And these tend to come
back down to accounting.
So in the same way that our
corporate carbon footprint
last week followed our
financial accounting rules.
This is much more in the vein
of managerial accounting,
where I'm trying to make certain
decisions that reflect what's
actually going on as opposed
to just necessarily following
some rules.
Cut off rules we covered.
One thing with the
end of life-- so this
was back in the appendix
of the document.
But this is essentially
illustrating
the four different cut
off rules that they
could apply for the waste
management of the paper towels.
So the base scenario used,
essentially, this cut off rule.
So what they're saying is that
you have the first product that
takes the virgin material in,
you produce it, you use it,
then it goes back to re-pulping.
So it's essentially recycled and
turned into a second product.
Again, has its own life cycle.
You might repulp
it a third time,
and again, it has
its own life cycle.
And then maybe it's reached
the end of its useful life
and it's going to go
to waste management.
So all of these are essentially
the same supply chain,
but we can divide up the
impacts between the three
different product
life cycles based
on how we divide up who
gets credit for which
of these burdens.
I think they used
the cut off rule
in this one, which is the first
product took credit or took
the impact for all
of the production
of the virgin material
and all of the use.
But then once it moved off
into the recycling system,
all of that impact was
associated with the products
that went on down the line.
The second product took
care of all that repulping,
the burden that went on there.
And the third product
took that second set
of repulping and the final
waste management disposal.
So if you think of this as
comes from the original forestry
and paper production,
and this is
the final when it gets
thrown away in the landfill.
It's deciding who got
those various impacts.
And you can see that
they've drawn, depending
on where you want
to draw the impact,
there's a lot of different
rules you can apply.
And it's mainly a
judgment call on which one
you think makes sense.
Since it's not
entirely clear that one
is better than the other, these
decisions are, in essence,
always going to be arbitrary.
OK.
So that was the first
step, the goal and scope.
The second step is the
inventory analysis.
So this is when you have to go
out and identify and quantify
all of those impacts from
the production system.
So in this case, it's a pretty
straightforward process,
but not easy.
So simple, but not easy.
So the first is you build
a model of the system.
This is sort of their
stylized version of what
the model of the system is.
If you look at a more
detailed life cycle assessment
study that's really getting down
into the production process,
you might see a list of, say,
hundreds of different processes
drawn out in a flow diagram.
A lot of the reason
for this is that it's
coming from people from
a science background that
have done this.
So it tends to follow
a mass or energy flow,
where every time
something comes in,
you have to trace it and figure
out where it exits the system
or where it's going
into, with the idea
being that nothing should be
getting lost along the way.
If I have 100 kilograms of
material coming in as input
and 86 kilograms of it go
into the production system,
then that other 14
kilograms better
get traced where it's going.
Whether it's getting turned
off into waste or burned
or whatever happens to it.
So that's generally
the first part.
And this building a
model of the system
is something that
goes on by looking
at who are my suppliers,
what are my inputs,
where do I get different
things from, where's
energy coming into the system,
electricity, all of that.
Where are things
being transported
between, where are my different
facilities located, interviews,
studying the bill of materials,
looking at your procurement,
analyzing where
your customers are.
This tends to be going
through the records of trying
to figure out and map
out the supply chain.
So from that standpoint, it's
pretty simple understanding
what's going on, not
necessarily always
easy to do since this
tends to be very data-
and labor-intensive to go
through and figure this out.
The even worse part
is that once you've
identified all these processes,
is identifying the inputs
and outputs.
So in the inputs we have
raw materials, energy,
and other products that are
coming in, and on the output,
it's our emissions, to air,
to water, and to waste.
So everything that comes into
the system and everything that
goes out.
I'm essentially
drawing a boundary
around my system
which, inside it, may
have a number of different
processes going on.
What I'm looking for is, once
I've mapped out that process,
I need to go through
and identify where
are all my inputs and outputs.
If this is my system
boundary, these
should all be raw materials
coming in, energy coming in,
and all of the
emissions going out.
And so one way to do that is
to go through step by step.
This is a production
facility, start tracking.
What energy are they
using, how many units did
they produce, things like that.
So this tends to be the
time consuming part of it,
but pretty straightforward in
terms of what you need to do.
So in terms of the
study that we looked at,
how did they go
about doing this?
They talk a little bit about it.
It's kind of vague
in some areas,
but they talk about the
main process that they use.
What do they start with
for the Dyson system.
AUDIENCE: Bill of materials?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
the bill of materials.
Are you familiar with
the bill of materials?
Or the B-O-M, the BOM.
This is basically just a
listing of all the parts
that are going into it.
If you were to look
at a higher level,
you might look at it as the
fan, the motor, the housing,
et cetera.
These are the different
parts that go into it.
And these in themselves
may have a number
of other different
materials that go into them.
So if you look at it, it's
sort of a diagram that
sort of spreads out, where
you have one piece here,
and it might have
a couple of inputs.
And those might, in turn,
have their own inputs.
And essentially, it's
going to expand out.
I'm going to have a big
list of all of the materials
that I have.
So in this case, they went
through and took the data
that Dyson gave
them and said, we
have the bill of
materials for all of this.
And the trick was to turn that
into the life cycle inventory.
And so what they did is they
took the bill of materials
data-- and they call it
the bill of activities
because they also have data
about the activities that
are going on, the energy
use that's going on
in the production phase--
and they matched it up
with inventory data.
In this case, you
can think of the work
that would go on to actually
go and do one of these.
Especially because
you think of-- they
mention in there something
like the optic housing that
was on one of them that
detects when the hand goes in
and when it comes out.
You think, that has a lens,
it has a microprocessor,
it has whatever
else goes into it.
And all of those products
have their own complex supply
chains.
So the minute that we
mention one of these,
if we're taking this
cradle to grave approach,
then we need to
start tracking each
of those products up all the
way through their suppliers.
And so they're
buying that assembly
from some supplier
who in turn is buying
a processor from this
company, and they're
buying a lens from this
buying a plastic housing
from this company.
And that company does some
kind of injection molding,
and they buy raw
plastic from here.
So you can imagine
they're going to have
to start tracing all of that
up, what a labor that would be
to try to do that for
a complex product,
or even a relatively
simple product.
So what they've done is
they've gone out and found
this inventory data,
which generally
comes from third party sources.
So if you look at how you would
do one of these life cycle
inventories, usually there's a
couple of big software vendors
that make tools that
help you do this.
SimaPro, GaBi, are
some of the big ones.
They, in turn, license
databases from other companies.
ecoinvent was the one that
was used in this study,
and they mention that in here.
So ecoinvent is a company
that goes out and actually
tries to do that work.
They try to go out and
look for common products
and go out and examine what
types of inputs do they have,
what goes on at the factory,
how much energy does
it take to make it,
what are all the inputs
and outputs to the
environment, and they sort of
start building up these.
So then they have a database
that tells you things
like this type of steel has
this sort of impact, here
are its inputs and
outputs, different types
of plastic, et cetera.
And you go through and
you match those up.
So now it says, I don't
necessarily need to go through
and do all of this tracing
of everything for me.
The software, the
database that I'm using,
is going to have some
of that in there.
It's enough for me to say that
this particular pieces is,
say, 2.3 pounds of
this type of material.
I'm going to go out and match
that up with the database
to do all of that
upstream tracking
and tracing of what's going on.
They talk about
this in the study,
though, because this is going
to run into some problems.
What are some of the issues
that they had with this?
So there's a lot of different
products that go into it.
What do you do when you
run into a product that's
not in the database.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
they didn't
have specific data on
the different material
covers for the hand dryers,
so they just averaged them.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In that case, that was a
slightly different issue,
but related.
Because that one,
they were relying
on-- they were taking the
information from a third party
that had done the study already,
and had just already averaged
the impact of the
housing together.
Rather than not
being able to find--
I suppose it probably
fits in there.
Nobody had done
this study and said,
here is the impact for
a Xlerator housing made
of plastic or made of aluminum.
So it is probably the same.
Some of the stuff, like there
was no galvanized steel.
They said there
was none of this.
There was no-- I
forget which type.
There was some type of bleached
paper that they didn't have.
And this was related to the
recycled paper towels and some
of these issues.
So essentially, they had a list
of maybe 20 different materials
or so that were listed in
these bill of materials
or that were included
in the system
that they didn't have data for.
So they had to go through
and sort of create
their own version
of some of these.
So they said well, one thing
you can do is use proxy data.
So they said, we don't
have this specific type
of bleached paper, so we'll
just use as a substitute
this type of bleached paper.
Or they said, we don't
have galvanized steel,
but we have regular,
this type of steel,
and then we're going to
add to that the impact that
would go with this process of
applying the coating to it.
Even with this
inventory data, you're
going to run into trouble
finding all the products
that you need to do to do this.
And so it's generally
not something--
you're going to have to make
some compromises as you go,
in terms of figuring
out what you can include
and how to get around
some of these limitations
that you might have.
Now, once they did
that, they went through.
They had this chart in
here which was showing,
essentially, what they had.
This is the assumption that they
used to generate the inventory,
because part of it
was that they had
to go through the
manufacturing and identify
how much energy per unit.
And then they had to
go through, and then
based on this, the life cycle,
how many times would it draw.
They had to go through and
capture how much material
was going into each of these.
One of the assumptions
they had to make
was data about the
scrappage rates.
Because part of this
is that the goal is
to understand all
of those inputs
that come into the
system and the emissions,
and then what is
my useful output.
So if I take in 100
kilograms of plastic,
but only 85 kilograms of plastic
end up in the final unit,
because the other
15 goes to waste,
you have to make sure to
allocate the emissions related
to that 15 kilograms of waste
to those final products.
So it's not enough just to look
at the end bill of materials.
They had to make
some assumptions
about what goes on the
manufacturing process
and how that relates to it.
And so at the end, once
they've gone through this,
they have enough to move
on to the next stage.
I'm going to skip this
piece here and talk
about our next stage, which
is the impact analysis.
So this is where they go through
and finally, now that they
have, for each of those
different products systems,
they've made all of
these assumptions,
they've put together the impact.
They're ready to go
ahead and determine
what the environmental impact
of each of those products was.
So there's essentially
two steps that
go on in the impact assessment,
referred to as classification
and characterization.
So classification,
the first one,
essentially that inventory
analysis you have
is going to list things
like all of the outputs, all
of my emissions to air.
How much carbon dioxide, how
much carbon monoxide, all
of these different
types of gases.
But if I'm interested in the
global warming potential,
I really only need to
know which of these
are the greenhouse gases.
So I'm going to go through
in the classification step,
and I'm going to look at all
of these different outputs
that I have to the
atmosphere, and I'm
going to gather together the
ones that are contributing
to global warming.
That would be the first step.
That would be the
classification step.
And you're going
to need to do that
for each of the different
environmental impact categories
that you might have.
So they'll go
through and do that.
And the second one is
the characterization.
So if we look at it in terms of
the global warming potential,
after I've classified and
gotten together my listing of,
OK, how much carbon dioxide,
how much methane, how much
nitrous oxide,
characterization is
when we apply those
global warming potentials
and actually turn that
into a unit of output.
Carbon dioxide equivalence.
And this applies to a wide
range of different environmental
impacts that you might study.
What were some of
the impacts that they
chose to study in this one?
They had a couple of basic
ones and then some more complex
ones.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CO2 emissions.
And they didn't really
understand how to get water.
But they said they
included water,
and then they said they
didn't, so I don't really
understand what went on there.
PROFESSOR: So they mentioned
a couple things in there.
They had the global
warming potential,
they have the carbon
footprint, essentially.
They had water use.
AUDIENCE: Land occupation?
PROFESSOR: So we'll get
to that in a second.
So they had, they called it CED.
Cumulative Energy-- yeah.
Then they had--
remember what the name
of the more complex one was?
AUDIENCE:
[? Along the lines of ?] IMPACT
2002+.
PROFESSOR: They had something
called IMPACT 2002+,
I think it was called.
So what they did, when
they went through this,
they made a distinction
about some of these.
So the global warming
potential isn't environmental,
it's an impact category,
because it basically
does these two steps.
I gather my greenhouse
gases and then
I characterize the impact
using their global warming
potentials.
The water use and
cumulative energy demand
aren't really impact categories.
They're treated as such
by a lot of people,
but they made the
point in the study,
they're not technically
impact areas.
And the reason for
that is that there's
no actual characterization
that goes on.
So for water use and
cumulative energy demand,
they just went back
through the inventory
and said during all these
steps in the process,
I'll just sum up how much
water was used at each stage.
At the end, I get a total
amount of water use.
But there's no attempt to
turn that into something
more complicated.
There's no attempt to rate.
You can think of if I'm using
good, clean drinking water
or if I'm using salt
water from the ocean.
You might think that
those would have
different environmental impacts,
because most people don't care
if I'm using up the
salt water as opposed
to using up the clean water.
So you could think they're not
actually really investigating
the impact of those, they're
just calculating them
so you can see how much water
and how much energy they use.
And specifically for the
cumulative energy demand,
they mention that it's a proxy
for a lot of other things.
The more energy intensive
the production process
is, that's tied to a lot of
other environmental impact
categories.
So they're sort of used as a
proxy, but not really an impact
category.
So we had the single
use indicators.
Cumulative energy demand on
the side, and global warming
potential, right.
And we can go through, and
they've calculated the carbon
footprint for each of these
different products based
on that inventory
analysis and broken it up
into the different
stages of life.
And you can do the same thing
for the cumulative energy
demand where, in
this case, they're
measuring it in how many
kilojoules of energy they use.
Those are pretty simple.
But the more complicated ones
are this one like IMPACT 2002.
In this case, that's
because it has
number of different
factors going in,
and it's sort of divided up
into a two stage approach.
Which is the first
thing you have,
just like with global
warming potential,
they started with the
inventory results.
Then they went
through and created
what they called a number
of midpoint categories.
So if you look at
what IMPACT 2002 is,
it's divided up into all of
these different things that
are counting everything from
carcinogens to ozone depletion
to how much mineral
extraction you're doing,
aquatic acidification.
So a number of different
environmental impacts.
This is getting at a
lot more broader scope
than what we would get if
we just looked at energy
or global warming potential.
It goes through sort
of the same process
that you had before
which is, now I'm
going to look at my
inventory and I'm
going to classify all of my
emissions that are carcinogens,
and I'm going to group together
and figure out how much
I have of each different type.
They're going to go
through this for each
of these different
midpoint categories.
Then what they've done is that
they've combined these, then,
into a second set.
So they figured out how
many of the different types
of carcinogens,
how many of these.
And then they
relating these again
to overall indicators
that capture a broad set.
All of these are things
that impact human health.
So they're grouping
these together
and one they're
calling human health,
they're grouping all
of these together
into ecosystem quality,
climate change has its own,
and then they have resources.
So that in itself is a
pretty complicated process,
because if you read
about it or looked
into some of these
charts, this is
what happened is that
they-- and I'm not
even sure how you do this.
So the carcinogens
are being measured
in-- I don't know what that is.
I need to brush up
on my chemistry.
But it's some kind of grams
of some chemical equivalent.
So they've taken all of
the different outputs
that they have that
are carcinogens,
and they've found a way
to measure them in terms
of some equivalent units.
I assume this is producing
the same amount of carcinogens
as 0.277 grams of
whatever that compound is.
That's how they've gone
through, and for each
of these categories,
they've created
some measure that they're
going to use, some equivalent.
So respiratory
inorganics, we can
assume that these have the
same impact as it would
if you produced this many
grams of particulate matter.
2.5 millimeter
particulate matter, right.
Or whatever that is.
They've gone through and,
for each of these categories,
they've come up with
a way to do this.
And so this is pretty complex
and probably nobody on earth
is enough of an
expert to be an expert
on each of these categories.
So what they've done is
they've gathered together
experts from all of
these different areas
to figure out how you
would go through and judge
each of these.
And they actually go a step
further from this, actually,
two steps further from this.
So you can see for
each of these products,
we're going to get all of
these different ratings.
And the question is, how
do we put all of these
together in terms
of an indicator.
Because I can look at what
the value is for an Airblade
aluminum, and I compare that to
Cotton Roll towels, and I see,
well, Cotton Roll towels
have less carcinogens.
Does that make them better
than the Dyson Airblade.
And the question
is, that depends.
Because if you start looking
at some of these other impact
categories, you find ones where,
well, that actually contributes
a higher value,
290 to 118 in terms
of terrestrial ecotoxicity.
So then you have to come
back through and figure out
a way to balance all of these
different impacts together.
And that's what that
impact system does.
It essentially
produces two things.
So first, they group
all of those together.
They took all those human
health impacts together
and created a single indicator.
So they're bringing
together the carcinogens,
the inorganic respiration,
all of these different types
of impacts that they said
impacts human health,
and they put them all on
a single unit of measure.
Which I believe is disability
adjusted life years.
So if any of you are
following health care,
that's how you
measure when should we
pay for this type of
health care or not.
This is one of the
things that you do.
You try to judge what the
consequences of it will be,
and then you have to make
some trade offs about,
would it be better to
be blind in one eye
or walk with a limp and
all of these things.
So it's very
complicated and requires
a lot of value judgments to
get into some of these levels.
The nice thing about these
categories like IMPACT 2002
is that they have
what would hopefully
be a panel of experts going
through and doing this in sort
of a peer reviewed fashion.
And they're coming
up, and so now this
is giving me a human
health comparison
of these different products.
So it's bringing together all of
those different seven or eight
different indicators that
impacted human health
and put them together
on one scale.
And they do the same thing
for ecosystem quality.
And in fact, you can
take it a stage farther,
which is that you can put
these all together in terms
of eco points.
So then that makes the balance
between how much human health
would you be willing to trade
off against how much ecosystem
quality.
So the important thing
to remember about this
is that as you start-- so that's
very nice when I have something
like IMPACT 2002 because,
theoretically, I can compare
these systems and
I can get a picture
of the overall
environmental quality.
Not just looking
at one single issue
like global warming
potential, and not
having to look simultaneously
at 27 different indicators
and decide how I
want to trade it off.
I've hopefully got
some experts out there
that have done that already,
and I can sum everything up
in terms of, say, one
unit of eco points.
But the important
thing to remember
is that when you do that,
you're making value judgments.
That's built into the
system that scores that.
It's deciding how much
you're willing to trade off
these different categories.
So finally, the last step we
do is the interpretation phase.
So this was actually
the long one,
when we looked at
the study overall,
because they went
through and trying
to interpret all those earlier
results in terms of what
the goal in the study was.
And essentially to do that, they
had to go through and do all
sorts of uncertainty
analysis on that
to make sure all of those
assumptions they made
along the way were still
valid when they tried
to go back and interpret it.
If you wanted to come back and
make a claim that the Dyson
Airblade was better
than the others,
you better make sure that all
of the limitations in the study
aren't going to impact that.
So they essentially
did three types.
They did a sensitivity analysis,
they did uncertainty analysis--
which was really
two different types,
one was a scenario
uncertainty and the other
was a bill of
activities analysis.
So in terms of what they
did, the sensitivity analysis
was pretty straightforward.
They basically went through all
of those assumptions they made,
and they had a lot of them.
There were probably 12 or 15
different major assumptions
that they made.
And they did a one
factor at a time change
to test the impact of that.
So they went through and
some of them, they tested.
When it goes to waste,
there's a percentage
of that that gets incinerated.
So they tested how that changed,
and different countries that
have different waste systems
and different ways of taking
care of the waste will
do that differently.
So they went back
and tested the impact
of changing that percentage
on the scenarios.
If we look at the
scenarios, none of these
really get changed because
they're not really sending much
to waste that's getting burned.
And these change a little bit.
But overall, looking at
these different scenarios,
you get a very similar
picture than you did before.
So it's not particularly
sensitive to the assumption
that we have here.
The other one has to do with
the intensity of the drying time
on the system.
And so in this case, you start
to get a very different picture
between different
scenarios, where
you have some of these
that are getting definitely
higher impact and
changing as we go through.
So the sensitivity analysis
was pretty straightforward.
Go through one at a time,
changing those factors
between some different
values, seeing what impact
it has in the system.
The two things we
said it identified
were the electricity
and the drying time,
which drying time
scenario you used.
So it identifies those two as
sort of the major ones that
can affect the system.
But one of things it
doesn't really capture
is that it does all
this one at a time.
And especially those
two are related,
so if I'm off on how
long I dry, then I'm
also off on my assumption
about the intensity
of the electricity.
Those two factors
might compound together
to make my results even worse.
So this only
captures what happens
when they did it one at a time.
So they went through and did a
scenario uncertainty analysis.
And essentially, they had
20 different parameters,
and they had a range
for each of them.
And they assumed the
distribution, uniform
or some other type,
and they went through
and did a Monte Carlo
simulation, where
they did 20,000 different
simulation runs where they
randomly picked a value
from that distribution,
and calculated the impact on
each of the different product
systems.
So this is global
warming potential,
and you get some
sort of distribution
about what the impact of the
different products looked like.
You can see how it
changes based on all
the different assumptions of
what the possible range was.
One of the important things
they did with this is you
get some overlap.
But if we look at
that, the Airblade
is definitely the lowest in
terms of where it's shifted.
But there's definitely
some overlap
between some of
these other systems,
and one of the
things they did is
they went back and checked that
just because there's overlap
doesn't mean that Xlerator
was lower than this.
It just means in
certain scenarios,
the Xlerator was lower
than what the Airblade had
in certain scenarios.
So what they did is
they did a check.
Because you can think that
some of the assumptions
might affect only one
product or the other.
But I may have underestimated
the drying time on the Xlerator
and overestimated the
drying time on my product,
and that may cause the
products to shift in terms
of which was preferred.
Some of the others, like if the
average electricity makes up
the grid, I wouldn't
expect those
to be different between
one product and the other.
They're both using the
same electrical supply,
so my assumptions about
the impact of the grid
should be the same between them.
So they made sure
they did that check
by each time they ran one of
these scenarios, they compared.
Did the Airblade have a
better performance than, say,
the Xlerator, and went through.
And even though you get
this overlapping like this,
they still found something
like 98% of the scenarios,
the Airblade was better.
Finally, the last thing
they did was looking
at the bill of activities.
So for every emissions
factor, essentially,
and for every input to
each of those systems,
they assigned an
uncertainty level to it,
and assumed a distribution,
and did another simulation
so they'd get a range of
different products like this.
So these are just three
different types of analysis
they went through
to try to figure out
how much those assumptions
and that uncertainty
impacted what the results were.
So the big thing, though,
is that even after they
went through with that,
the Dyson Airblade still
showed the lowest
impact in general.
Under certain scenarios, it may
be that the Xlerator performs
better, but under
most scenarios,
they were pretty confident that
the Dyson showed up better.
They broke it out by
different types of scenarios
and said when one was going
to be better than the other.
So in the conclusion
they identified
what are the most
sensitive parameters, what
was the key driver, the
environmental impact, and what
was the general overall
environmental performance
comparing the two,
taking into account
all of that sensitivity.
OK.